so what is this joe rogan is literally
five foot three
um someone wrote that in the sky over
weho
yeah because it started i guess with a
wedding proposal that's what
that's what luke told us so someone
propose
that looks like it says toe standing on
my roof and it said will you marry me
molly pratt
said she said yes i love you more than
anything um
can't wait to spend my life with you
till death do us part whole thing and
then it said
oh my goodness and it said got one more
thing to say
joe wrote what joe rogan
what joe rogan is
literally
it's literally five foot three what the
[ __ ]
kind of funny i guess that's kind of
funny yeah
that's pretty funny yeah is he five foot
three
what if he was i mean that was pretty
short if he is
he looks taller than that that's what
was wrong with that nothing well i mean
nothing i mean i'm oh haha
fellow he's literally five foot he's
five foot seven
five foot seven so shut the [ __ ] up
wrong joe is five foot seven actually
joe is five foot seven
so that's not even funny yeah it's not
funny because it's not even true it's
not true it's a lie
yeah literally so wrong yeah what a
loser wasted all that money to write
that in the sky
yeah yeah exactly
[Laughter]
idiots dude don't even know the host of
the greatest podcast in the [ __ ]
face of the earth yeah on earth god
pisses me off dude you know what's crazy
he could literally
beat everyone's ass i know that's what's
crazy it's like all these people that
talk [ __ ] about him joe could literally
[ __ ] you up
[Laughter]
upsetting bro can we get dramatic
lighting
it just pisses me off you know yeah like
not only is he like dedicated to like
expanding his own mind through like
hallucinogen like you know
everything exactly sauna saunas exactly
who's the gender like whatever
so open to experience what was that what
what was that one that you said what
what was that one what did you say
eugenics
i said hallucinogenic oxidogenics yes
exactly
exactly what's eugenics
is that a supplement joe's really into
it you should check it out
it's a supplement yeah i think it's a
supplement company
eugenics
anyway sorry go ahead nothing it's just
like he's so cool
like people don't get it you know yeah
dude it's like who else do you know
that can fight the stand-up comedy
and also can literally kick your [ __ ]
ass right
like you don't even these don't even
matter at that point because there are
so many other things though
yeah they're for sure like the list goes
on yeah move to austin
that is sick that is sick who else do
you know that can do that
um go hunting yeah kill a deer yeah
be friends with alex jones like people
talk about like
literally killing the game joe literally
does that
like people say oh i'm killing the game
they don't actually but joe kills the
game because like he
kills deer yeah he kills the game like
he literally kills game yeah and then he
eats it yeah
so which is sick and he fights
and he can kick your ass so sick
so yeah i don't appreciate anyone first
of all incorrectly making fun of his
height
secondly taking any kind of digs at a
dude who could
literally kick your [ __ ] ass yeah
he's not literally five three he's
literally five seven
yeah so okay i can't just
go back
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
sorry i'm just getting out of character
right now it's getting a little peeved
off
gotta be careful never don't ever insult
my boy joe don't ever install my boys
once you get into that once you get into
that character it's like
you can't escape it
like i can't even think right now
because somebody [ __ ] disrespected
joe
every time we're a little bit off the
game today we go sorry i'm just [ __ ]
still distracted by the fact that
someone said joe's literally five three
when he's not he's literally five seven
it's like have you even watched a single
[ __ ] episode of his [ __ ] show
did you not watch fear factor i'm sorry
i grew up on that [ __ ]
he like literally has like doctors and
like astrophysicists and like so many
different kinds of people
on his podcast yeah it can like
conversate with all of them
conversate love that dude
conversate yeah all these people that
are like absolute morons it's the best
fake word
conversation yeah it's awesome bro
i almost got stabbed last night what
it was a dream i just had to i just had
to do that
i just had to do that okay i woke up
this morning i'm like i'm
this is a bit i woke up from the dream
i'm like this is a bit i'm gonna tell
cody
and i knew you were gonna freak out yeah
because
i mean it's a pretty intense thing to
say you got you yeah that dude almost
got stabbed last night
dude you had me going man when you said
that i was like what in my head i was
like what
what kind of situation would he be and
then you it's a dream and
i'm joking my brain was totally gone i'm
like you're
oh oh oh [ __ ] my boy seriously in peril
and what what my dog almost got stabbed
last night
i'm almost in peril my boy is seriously
in peril
bro hold up are you telling me last
night you were in grave danger
you were joking you [ __ ] dude
you effort dude forever man
yeah i thought you almost literally got
stabbed i mean in my dream i did
no i actually had a dream where i had a
kid last night and you stabbed your kid
and i stabbed him after that jody
episode
jody aries the three-hole wonder
yeah by the way if you missed the bonus
last time oh yeah bad for you yeah you
got it
that was that rich bonus episode
patreon.comgang by the way if you want
to get in on that
dude this dream i had last night i
almost want to
write and shoot as a scene because it
was so
crazy i i'm in a bathroom at a wawa
okay already bed yeah
one month i go
in i'm walking up to the bathroom i hear
the screaming it's like
come on man come on like
i go inside and there's a dude reaching
over the top of a stall giving another
guy a wedgie
like as tall as the stall like he's a
it's a tall ass dude and he's just
ripping this dude's underwear out of his
ass and the dude's screaming like for a
dear life like
come on man let it go let it go and i
turn around i'm like
[ __ ] i don't i need to pee though
so i go in i'm like i'm not a [ __ ] and
i go in and i go pee
and the stall i'm into there's no toilet
it's just the
like the pipe where the toilet would be
so it's like a hole
i'm like i'm not gonna complain i'm just
piss i'm pissed right into the drain i
can do it
so i start peeing in the hole and as i'm
peeing in the hole
there's a someone from the stall
next to me is pissing on my shoe okay
like
being funny i'm like god damn it
so i walk out of the stall and there's a
dude waiting there
with like an assassin's creed knife it's
like wrapped around his wrist and it's
like sticking like
out from underneath his hand and he
grabs me he's like hold on bro
i'm like what how was he peeing huh no
he wasn't the peeing one he wasn't the
peeing
he was just waiting outside the stall
and then
so then the dude who peed on my shoe he
walks out of the stall and he's like a
shot caller he like zips up his pants
and he like looks at me
and he like looks at the guy and he's
like do it and then
he's like him i'm like what the [ __ ]
what did i do it's fine it's fine these
shoes weren't that expensive anyways
[Laughter]
and so they start like talking to each
other and they get distracted and i use
that as my opportunity to [ __ ] bolt
i run and then they come out of the
stall and it's three of them
and i forget what i'm standing outside
the bathroom with they're like these
two people are supposed to be my friends
or some [ __ ] and it was like some video
game thing where they came out and
they're like do you see that
[ __ ] and i just looked away
and they just kind of you know just left
me alone like some npc behavior
and i woke up thinking dude did i just
get my shoe peed on and almost stabbed
that was crazy that's a wild dream i
know
it's just like i normally hate when
people tell me their dreams
i know because they don't it doesn't
mean you know it's just like you could
have just made that up
yeah yeah just sitting here like what
whoa that's so crazy
yeah and then like and then like i did a
backflip
and then carrot top was there no you
know my dreams were real because i
didn't do anything cool
yeah yeah someone humiliated me they
peed on my shoe
and then they tried to kill me and i
screamed i'm scared internally